okay so in the latest issue of Doctor
Who magazine Russell T Davies had some
quotes in regards to the fact that Jody
Whitaker when she regenerated into David
Tennant the clothes changed as well now
these quotes have been taken out of
context all over Twitter what it amounts
to that I can sum up quickly and I'll
put them up you can pause the video if
you want to read them in full is that he
did not want to appear like tenant was
doing drag now some took that as a
denigration of the very idea of someone
in quote unquote women's clothes Davies
had more to say than just that bullet
point though pointing out that the image
of the masculine doctor in the just
recently departed feminine Doctors close
is something that the UK tabloids would
latch on to so while there is a
conversation to be had over whether or
not he came to the right conclusion I
can respect the decision-making process
that was based around acknowledging the
realistic environment of what things are
like in the UK right now I'm still going
to hold out some hope that there will be
a story reason for this having happened
even though we now know what the meta
reason is